هاني كان يتحدث عن قصف في رفح طال منزلين
على بعد 200 متر من المكان الذي كان فيه
تقريبا نتحدث عن نقل العمليات العسكريه
الى الى رفح هل مثل هذا القصف هو مؤشر على
ذلك يعني ممكن ممكن ان يكون قصف تمهيدي او
قصف من اجل كما جرى في الشمال يعني قبل ان
يتقدموا الى الشمال والى الوسط والى خان
يونس كانوا هناك تدمير تدمير مجمعات سكنيه
تسويه مباني بالارض قصف لمناطق واسعه طبعا
المقصود فيها ليس فقط القصف التدميري او
التمهيدي من اجل تقدم قوات وانما ايضا
لاسباب عديده منها قتل اكبر عدد ممكن من
الفلسطينيين وكما سمعنا ان معظم الشهداء
هم من
الاطفال وخاصه حينما يكون بنك الاهداف
ينفذ بساعات الليل هذا هذا يعني هناك قصد
من سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي ان يقتل اكبر عدد
ممكن من الناس لانه في حاله الليل يكون
الناس بالتاكيد في البيوت وخاصه ان هناك
يعني منطقه
مكتظه بالاهالي وبالسكين وهذا يعني يعس طب
ع ما يؤكد عليه الاسرائيليون وحلفائهم اذا
ما كنت تتابع حديثهم دائما ان
الاسرائيليين ام يحرصون على بذل اقصى ال
الحذر لتفادي ان يكون
هناك قتل مدنيون ولكن ما ما تتحدث عنه
سياده اللواء الان يشير الى
العكس بالتاكيد هم دائما وابدا يعني لا
يتحدثون عن حجم الخسائر الحقيقيه ويتحدثون
عن اهداف بانهم يستهدفون المقاومه ورجال
المقاومه علما بانه رجال المقاومه يشتبكون
مع الجنود الاسرائيليين حيث حث ما تواجدوا
ولكن الاحياء هي احياء مدنيه وانا اعتقد
انه حتى وزير الخارجيه بلينكن اليوم قال
هنا هناك عدد هناك عدد من المدنيين اي
وقعوا من خلال قصف الطيران اثناء
استهداف المناطق والمباني السكنيه حتى قال
انني لا يعني افكر كثيرا بالليل في اطف في
قتل الاطفال هذا اعتراف من بلينكن بان
هناك اباده جماعيه وان هناك استهداف
للمدنيين وان حينما نقول ان هناك 80% من
الشهداء ومن الجرحى هم من النساء ومن
الاطفال انا اعتقد لانه هناك هناك الان
معلومات حقيقيه تصل الى البنتاجون وتصل
الى العالم كله الذي يشاهد بالصوت والصوره
وبالتاكيد
حينما يتحدث العسكريون وخاصه الامريكان
الموجودين في داخل اسرائيل مع مع في غرفه
العمليات مع اسرائيل يعرفون انه قصف سلاح
الجو بالليل هذا يعني استهداف للمدنيين
وليس للمقاومين لانه المقاوم لا يتواجد
بالليل في المباني ولا يميز
الطيران لا حتى بالليل ولا بالنهار وهذا
يعتبر قصف عشوائي وهو من جرائم الحرب التي
ترتكب من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي اذا كان
الاسرائيليون يفكرون في القيام بعمليات
عسكريه في رفح فكيف ي
مكن مقارنه ذلك بما حدث في مدينه غزه وفي
خان يونس ما ما ما هي طبيعه رفح او
المختلف في رفح
عسكريا يعني اولا رفح مكتظه بالسكان رفح
صحيح انه 60 ر ولكن لا يوجد فيها منطقه
خاليه كما كما هي خان يونس وكما هي بقيه
المناطق الان الخيم خيم النازحين موجوده
في كل مكان هذا يعني ان اسرائيل مصممه على
مزيد من حرب الاباده الجماعيه والتطهير
العرقي فهل يمكن ان تقبل بهؤلاء النازحين
ان يعودوا الى منازلهم في الشمال وفي
الوسط هل ستضغط عليهم من اجل ان يتوجهوا
نحو الحدود المصريه ما المقصود ما المقصود
من عمليه اي رفح وخاصه انه يعني يتحدثون
عن محور فيلادلفيا
ويتحدثون عن انفاق ويتحدثون عن ق ويتحدثون
عن اسر كما تحدثوا في عن خانيونس ولكن لم
يجدوا شيء في خانيونس لذلك هم يريدون
تغطيه فشلهم في خان يونس وفي غزه وفي
الشمال من خلال هذه التراهات وهذه
الاحاديث بان هناك اهداف موجوده في رفح
وانا اعتقد النوايا النوايا ليست سليمه في
كل الاحوال وكما قال نتنياهو اليوم صرح
نتنياهو قال حينما توجهنا لحرب بريه قال
لا تذهبوا في حرب برئيه وقالوا لا تدخلوا
الى قطاع غزه دخلنا قطاع غزه والان يقولون
لا تذهبوا الى رفح سنذهب الى رفح فبالتالي
يبدو يبدو ان هناك نوايا عند الجيش
الاسرائيلي وعند القياده السياسيه
الاسرائيليه بان يتوجهوا ليس الى رفح فقط
والى محور فيلادلفيا وربما الى الضغط على
الاهالي والسكان من خلال يعني قتل الحياه
من خلال استهدافهم بالطائرات كما كما
يشاهد اليوم ومن خلال استهدافهم من الجنود
بالدبابات وبال الاليات
لتهجير وطبعا نحن نعرف انه الحياه عزيزه
على الانسان فبالتالي اذا ما تعرض هذا
الكم الكبير من الضغط من الطائرات ومن
الدبابات ربما سيجبر على النزوح شكرا
جزيلا من رام الله اللواء المتقاعد واصف
عريقات الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه